good morning Millennials we are so
excited to be live in studio with a good
friend of the toast
a personal icon and like hero of mine
medicine is Javeed and I can't say your
name without saying it the way I know
you guys aren't friends anymore but the
way resident person ate your mom doing
it but say it is it's so funny since I
am the offspring of my mother no one can
do a better Evita than me please grace
us with your Vida impersonation oh my
god if I'm wearing pink your face your
face look like piece of wood I would say
we're gonna give the glam today you look
sickening today Darian is here and she
did my makeup and hi everybody at Bravo
con like they were like whoever is doing
your beat you need to stick with her and
I was like yeah she's based in New York
City you are looking like the best I
think I've seen you look in the last 10
years I really like you looks I mean I
watched you on TV for have like Facebook
memories that tell me where I was eight
years ago six years ago you look so good
and I want to get into all the shot
stuff but I do have to say really
quickly that the new season of Shahs
started and it reminded me that your
wedding was two seasons ago
once he's gonna go it was last season it
was last season and when they were
recapping last season it reminded me
that your episode of your wedding was
the best piece of television ever made
ever like you walking down the aisle
actually like you're in a meet and greet
saying hi to everyone and then your mom
coming in wrong telling you you look
like piece of wood and then you getting
up to the altar and your husband being
like you can't look sick like it was
just the most I just want you know like
me and my group of friends we quote that
episode to each other like multiple
times a week you know you want to make
sure that your husband still wants you
when you're at the altar of course so
I'll take that compliment like for me
for him to like still sexualize me is
really important of course even more so
after children of course so you are here
now this is your second time on the show
being a mom cuz you were here a few
months ago yes and I'm so how was baby
Jim's okay so I travel now with a piece
of like his favorite toy
so that when I walk in like I'm already
strategizing that when I go home today
to the hotel room I'm gonna be holding
his favorite toy sorry know that like I
meant like he's gonna already be happy
that's actually really really smart yeah
bribing children yeah so do you feel
this is your first season now filming
with a baby I know that production did
hold for you because you added some
complications towards the end of your
pregnancy right yeah oh yes so how is
filming different now okay once you have
a baby
nothing else matters like the way that
you could relate to like your first
boyfriend that you were obsessed with
you didn't want to like do anything and
then when you weren't with him you were
like looking at your yeah but a baby is
that on fleek and times 10 or a million
because you really just want to be there
for his growth like I only want to be a
full-time mom I don't want to be one of
those mothers who's like launching 20
different things at the same time yeah
yeah because it's important for you to
be there but does the show give you the
flexibility to make your own schedule
like that it's kind of a dream well I'm
on a reality show yeah like I'm doing
the only thing that I know what to do
and that is living my life in front of a
camera and I'm gonna brag about this
only because no one no one ever needs to
produce a storyline for me no one ever
needs to talk me into being open true
and showing everything and so when I
only conduct myself that way and like
I'm not really like peddling any
products ever I'm like living my actual
life then they don't they don't need to
do anything for me because they're very
always treating me the same way which is
like our cameras are on so is that a dig
at some of your classmates that you're
not peddling probably every single
person that's ever done reality show
totally totally me that's actually very
true you've really never come at like
with some launch party for a brand that
never came to fruition yeah or nor do I
mean like I it's not just about that
because that's fine for whoever wants to
do it and we're not you know we're not
here to do anything that elevate other
people's endeavors or percent I'm just
saying that in terms of being able to
like genuinely have the ability to share
without feeling something like
embarrassed or right hand or wish I
could but I don't
know how do you know I mean and I think
my mom right I mean and so I think
that's why everyone's like so looking
forward to seeing you this season
because this is now the culmination of
so many years of you being open about
your struggle with fertility your
struggle with your relationship with
your mom you the struggle between the
relation ever gonna meet someone right
and so now it's like it's all happening
for you and if you weren't being like
you were so open for the last five years
like now it's like it's a celebration
it's just so great now I'm really
excited to show the world what we're all
going through when you have babies like
because different yeah like there's a
lot to cover with respect to the way
that your marriage and your relationship
gets better and it also gets challenged
anything from like what happens as a
woman where when you first have a baby
it's there's things that are happening
hormonal II that you don't even know if
you're happy or sad right and then
you're like oh wait what about me cuz
you've been carrying obsessively like a
baby needs round-the-clock care right
mhm so then you discover that you've not
even thought about yourself your body
your mind your friend group your family
your skin like it's yes my ski so one
time when um since having the baby I
came home didn't take off my makeup at
the end of the shoot I had like a Shaw's
pickup and the next thing you guys like
hairspray and foundation like it all
happened right here yeah and I like I
was like I had like a huge acne breakout
and I was like so are you gonna like
washed your face with soap again no yeah
but I mean if there's a next season then
we're gonna dive deeper into like what
motherhood and marriage becomes cuz
right again like if you're not seeing it
anywhere else you're gonna see it on
trust yeah and so we just started season
and I can't believe it's been like ten
years eight seasons and we got off but I
was explaining to Jackie is like you
know sometimes with these Bravo reality
shows like the cast mates aren't like
really best friends so they'll be
off-camera and they won't be hanging out
but you guys are like a true family true
family and so a true fam the first
episode it's not like we're dilly
dallying and then in the middle of the
season the gentleman comes
right no no we get right into naked
Jenga like right you actually weren't on
this episode because what were you
dealing with personally with the
pregnancy okay so I had a bed rest so
that first I had a bed rest which
literally meant that I had to lay down
flat right then I was like yeah cuz the
doctor said I could get up and then all
of a sudden I was diagnosed with a thing
that could cause a cut sudden stillbirth
so you come all the way to the end of
your pregnancy and you're told we have
to induce you so the inducement was I
guess I was going to say was a disaster
but what happened is in turn baby was
fine and then I had a placenta accreta
which basically means my placenta was
super attached to the uterus so all of a
sudden I'm four hours five hours later
on the in the delivery room in a state
of emergency and I got multiple blood
transfusions and little Roddick's and
plasma and then that's when you guys
started to see like she's in ICU
intubated in restraints and so hungry
sobbing crying that's when he reached
out to Reza Oh in that situation okay so
what we had gathered this is great
because like you know that like I was
here a few months ago and during Bravo
con and I was like I can't I feel like I
came here and I want to talk to you guys
yeah I can't because it hasn't aired
right yeah I finally here we are but we
had seen it all play out on social media
because there was a lot going between
you and Reza and with the video camera
from Reza's front lawn and so the people
like we were kind of understanding what
was going on but you weren't able to
tell us but now we're here we see that
the whole season is pretty much like the
culmination of you and Reza's friendship
ending right you know and by the way a
lot of the things that are on social are
very very skewed views yes
Reza put all that stuff out there right
no he shared everything and I basically
am just over here being a mom like I'm
not like I really don't think that I put
anything that was
out there that he did and so for me like
that moment when that I just told you
about that Tommy was upset and he
reached out to Reza that's really the
moment that our friendship took a turn
because he should have come yeah that's
what your honor everything yeah and
raced to the hospital yeah and it's very
difficult for Tommy like to justify his
best friend who stood at the altar
Johnny being there hopped on a plane
from here right and was there five hours
later so how do you you know now it's
like Tommy's seeing his best man I'm
saying my best right of maid of honor of
man Ivana yeah man of honor
yeah like but you're only like five
minutes away so you know that's when I
saw like Reza on watch what happens live
saying demise of our friendship or
something like that I was like well
there's my side is that it like where
how do you ever justify right not
showing up yeah for that and then we're
gonna see all that on the season you're
gonna see cuz what you saw on social is
nothing no right and so you're you're
gonna see to me it's all so mysterious
like it's genuinely from the bottom of
my heart like how did this happen how do
you get here like why don't you just
show up and have a converse why is it
like an episode of like Three's Company
where it's like there's a
misunderstanding and like you know
instead of just really like for me like
the biggest question for us is like
where were you right yeah do you feel
like now that you're a mom and your
priorities have shifted so much you
handle like fights with your friends
differently a hundred I I'm sorry I wish
there was something in our lives that we
could experience like you have a bottom
it's when you're 13 you have a concealer
on when you say but the way that you
look at life differently with the child
mhm
is you got out of compassion you have an
added lens of like what love really is
right really thinking about other people
so yeah I wish that there was something
in our lives that we could that could
like change us forever earlier so you
didn't have to have a child you're not
gonna in order to or
to feel this this level and lens of life
yeah I'm okay we got a lot of questions
about the season from Instagram this is
from Katherine and Cara her residents
book very highly of you on this show
last week what do you need from Reza to
mend the friendship Reza needs
Tommy's forgiveness more than me so
really one thing that I don't think that
Reza has stopped to consider is that how
much he hurt him and even she
disappointed him at that time yeah
mm-hmm
do you think that that's a possibility
that he could get Tommy's forgiveness I
don't know what Reza thinks I don't know
what Tommy thinks about that possibility
all I can do is hope because when think
about it this way you guys you just had
a baby and now your husband and your
best friend can't be in the same room
right it's a terrible position to be in
because of something that is really
between two completely other people yeah
that has really nothing to do with but
you're caught in the middle in a very
yeah fucked-up way yeah
what would this from Alex Latimer what
is what would the present day MJ say -
MJ season one there's been so much like
there's been so much positive change and
rough journeys along the way we you make
a plan god laughs what advice would you
give to the girl season one day one of
filming knowing and being through this
journey who is that this is from Alex
laughs it's a great question Alex loved
you very good thinker and yeah first
thing I would say is you should have
been in therapy like a good deep
analysis you have that mom you have a
dad that was sick the whole time that we
were shooting from the beginning right
and so you should have hired more help
like in this department yeah ever ever
ran a brush through and like what was
the advice that I would give to myself
no I mean those are the only two things
cuz like B I learned right you wouldn't
be here now if you didn't make those
mistakes yeah I was wild but also I was
definitely in a lot of pain yeah also
iconic and I think it's worth mentioning
thank you we also talked about it the
other way
times on the show like season 1 you what
she would say - - now you like how much
she would love you and like she's so
proud of you you know yeah that's nice
way to think about it not just like oh
the things I would do differently but
like the things I did right to get to
this place that's so sweet see you
you're gonna be an amazing mom oh my god
it's so nice a bitter cry from M so
Rocio how do you play naked Jenga
well hopefully you don't have saggy
boobs or balls Carsten aaron has being a
mom improves your relationship with your
own mother because we've seen the the
relationship she's she's nervous around
the baby so that doesn't help but she's
experiencing her own beautiful thing
which makes me warms my heart yeah yeah
it's gonna help me be more compassionate
motherhood for me has made me more
compassionate yeah you and as an only
child you're not taught a lot like
everything revolves around you true
we're so blessed with so many siblings
yeah it's actually really interesting
like a perspective of just another yeah
no but it's true cos like you know we're
so used to taking care of each other
that that bond really I think can
prepare you nicely yeah for motherhood
you seem like you're killing it I feel
like I want your like to have like a
million kids often where it's better you
look so sickening this outfit the shoes
what are your bound by Valentine's Day
plans surprise from my husband you
didn't tell me but I was gonna make it a
group thing and he was like no it's
Valentine's oh my god we love to do that
like oh it's our anniversary let's take
a group trip is in my heart I want a big
big family of everyone you love which is
it back to like where we are with like
my cast like I love my cast like my
heart aches yeah on levels that I'm
aware of that I'm not aware of that I
want to talk myself out of and be like
everything's fine but you're not they're
sad and like because that group trip
like when I see you guys you guys know
that we follow on social each other and
I love to see like your group trip with
your group videos like to me that is the
quintessential definition of
yeah family is all about like in those
moments when you're just like with the
people that you love having the best
time it's like yes that's what we're
always striving for like you've worked
hard so you can have those exactly
totally SEPA so it's like gonna make me
cry tears of joy tears of joy but like
you really bring such a fresh
perspective to everything I love you
I've loved watching you over the years
thank you for opening up I feel like a
lot of people really relate to your
journey and you being so open about your
issues with fertility like makes people
feel less alone and I just think you're
an icon and a hero and I've absolutely
loved watching you and to another 10
years of Shahs of Sunset okay yeah thank
you so much how's that sunset it's on
every Sunday Monday Sunday on Bravo
don't miss it yeah I watched it instead
of the Oscars like that's how good it is
thank you guys so much for watching we
will see you in a bit
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning shows we are sorry for our
delay here we are very excited we
ordered new couches literally three
months ago they decided to take three
months and then have the nerve to
deliver at 10:30 on a weekday like they
don't know that the morning toast is
live but we postponed our show about an
hour we got new couches they're suede
they're pink if you're listening as a
podcast hi you're missing out it is so
lovely to be here in our couches finally
finally there's so much more comfortable
there space for Theo he was not about
the Thrones like no it was always weird
for him he'd just leave on the floor he
was like um MJ started the show with us
but for podcasters you have listened to
her segments at the end it was so fun it
was just so insightful and something
about her like really makes me like
emotional I feel like she is like the
type of person who we watched on TV for
ten years and got to really see like the
full scale of her life is like a signal
girl is a girl looking for love but
who's a girl finding love is a girl
getting married struggling with
fertility and I just like she really
gives me like a full perspective on life
and I every time I talk to her I feel
like I'm gonna cry ya know in
perspective like now as a mom just she
understands what's important and nice to
talk to someone with their priorities
you know it's so rare to so rare so
regular show for you today we're gonna
recap the fast five stories we're gonna
hang out we're gonna have fun we're
gonna make it laughs it's our last show
of the week we're taking a long weekend
I've decided very last minute to hop on
a jet to Miami and buy a jet Nemean a
commercial airline and coach because
there was no first-class seats left so
I'll be in Miami this weekend so if
you're around come say hi I'm very
excited and I'm also gonna be in Florida
but not in Miami oh so we have one more
piece of the couch coming of course like
you know god forbid they could only do
her three out of four pieces like a cat
um and I just
I'm loving this couch I just feel more
comfortable like I can I'll just be more
comfortable to speak freely and we have
our new window film going up today so
our show on Tuesday which is our next
show is gonna be so premium like finally
we're really getting our [ __ ] together
it only took a few months but thank you
for bearing with us thank you for your
patience every day work in progress like
we told you yeah okay well we actually
have some great stories for you today so
I feel like it is time do you get it
yeah like let's just jump right in it's
literally noon you know it's literally
time for dinner so I think we should
jump right in right to the Fast Five
story is that you yes yeah I know you
think you're not you but it's you you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your
toast and while that's true you know I
don't feel like stepping on your toes so
for the second day in a row I actually
have nothing to say and I saw a bunch of
people like tweeting like way they don't
have any ads like nobody wants to work
with them like no actually Jackie and I
had planned on taking our honeymoon this
week and we ended up not taking our
honeymoon because work comes first so we
had canceled shows we cancelled ads and
then we ended up doing the shows and
there wasn't enough time to get the ads
back so that's why if you're like trying
to start writing threads about us like
[ __ ] off lol okay first story is like
happy and sad at the same time because
just showered is reporting that sophie
Turner and Joe Jonas are pregnant which
is incredibly happy but it makes me
wonder like why is just Jerrod reporting
this like where is that Instagram photo
that they've worked so hard on the
announcement is all very weird just
Jerrod came out with it and then other
people like enews and People magazine
started reporting it as true based on
the report from just Jared and then the
morning toast posted about it which
obviously means that it's true I have to
say the toasters we're talking about
this in the thread about the Grammy is
like a while ago so as always this is
not news to anyone who is a toaster I
personally was shocked I mean there's
pregnancy theories about everyone all
the time unless it's like oh I'm working
for the company making Kylie Jenner's
baby stroller she is pregnant like if
it's just like oh so if we turn her wore
this and she hasn't been seen here like
maybe she's pregnant I was genuinely
shocked like I feel like these two are
two of my friends on this very normal
life to Germany
dating for a few years being engaged for
a year having a baby after six months
and I'm so so happy for my friends I
love them and I love Sophie Turner
actually did you ever see her interview
with dr. Phil where she talks about how
she struggled so much with depression
especially during the like time when she
was super young on becoming a woman on
Game of Thrones
right and people were so mean to her
like she would read mean things about
her and I just like loved her and seeing
that episode where she said like so much
of how she like changed like the way she
felt about herself had to do with how
much Joe Jonas loved her she's like if
he's like he's so cool like he loves me
like I must be amazing like it was just
like so refreshing to hear someone talk
about like depression and self-esteem in
such a gun or --ml way you know
sometimes it comes at you like so
clinically and she was just shooting the
[ __ ] with dr. Phil and she was like
crying the whole dr. Phil interview
because she loves dr. Phil she thinks he
like changes lives so that was like when
she really got me I'm born as like a
full-time fan and I think that things
this is so great it's hard when you
achieve like such levels of success and
fame at the beginning of your career and
it's like kind of how kylie like you
feel like you really can't go or do
anything else if you run then she was on
the most talked about show globally and
like she was everyone's favorite
character like she she really reached
like this level of Fame where most
people don't ever achieve and at some
point it's like where do we go from here
and then I think having a child like
totally changes your life when you're in
that position
and that's why people like Kylie liked
you it's so young yeah I think it's a
little different on between Kylie and so
if we turn her like I'm a few different
levels like Kylie has a business that's
just like she could do whatever she
wants for the rest of her life like
Sophie it's like even though she was on
Game of Thrones like in the industry so
he's like what are you doing that yeah
of course Game of Thrones was like
another level of television that but
globally no one has really ever done
before yeah but it's an ensemble cast
like they're all in the same boat and
then they all are gonna have to live up
to this like pressure of not just being
the people from Game of Thrones for the
record she's not on the same level as
like you know Lord Varys like she was
really one of the same level as Emilia
Clarke totally Kate Harrington Cersei
yeah but then with the whole Jonas
Brother thing like she really became
like a another level of superstar she
superseded everyone in the cast and
she's building a nice life for herself
and at the end of the day that's all you
have is who you come home to so true
what's waiting for you after this
conversation we had with Minister
Mercedes like I just families everything
feels like maybe Sophie like had a
conversation with Mercedes I think that
she has her priorities in order I think
that if things had worked out
differently for Mercedes like she would
have been an amazing life coach
yeah but like she wouldn't be where she
is without the wife experience totally
totally yeah but like the person she is
now like I just hoped like everyone who
like loves Shahs of Sunset like gets a
chance to meet her and what's so crazy
is we just had Reza here and like
genuinely loved him as well and they're
not showing a lot I think that their
friendship they will come back together
of course but what Mercedes said which
if you're listening has a podcast you'll
hear in a bit was that a lot of the
reason they can't get on the same page
again is because Tommy refuses to
forgive for us which I totally get
because Reza didn't show up to go to the
hospital when she needed him and I do
agree we say that sentir toasters all
the time like if you don't show up for
your friends at the times when they
absolutely need you most thing you were
never friends to me we're no toda and
the friendship wasn't real but back to
sophie Turner where you'll never be
friends going
going flowers you know Jonah's posted an
Instagram today this morning just like a
random picture with his dog of him in a
towel like totally ignoring what's going
on I I respect it they'll do now it
could like not be true no I don't think
it's not true but I think in a month two
months she'll post the picture that she
wants to pose I think also it might be
early and I thought as a society we had
evolved past spoiling people's
pregnancies yeah um I guess not
I actually didn't spoil Mercedes's
pregnancy do you remember that yeah but
then you deleted it you know I I had
gotten a very very good tip from a
person who said it's 100% show someone I
know personally so I posted about it
which was kind of [ __ ] up and she left
a comment now I'm not and I Julie did it
immediately and then she came out with
her own pregnancy and she texted me and
she was like sorry I had this whole
thing set up with People magazine I'm
like no I'm sorry that's like so [ __ ]
up yeah I should have done that like
that's such a personal one I'm like the
most the biggest milestones in a
person's life like let them say it on
their own time even if we all know
they're pregnant like Kylie right even
though till the very end I was like a
little like one person I'm like she's
maybe not yeah but like that we owed her
that privacy privacy I totally agree and
this we just saw Sophie at the Grammys
like it's obviously early yeah II like
normal like no keep her give her some
privacy
yeah it's weird I feel I feel like I
can't remember the last time that this
took me
I consider it like the same line that
journalists don't cross when they don't
out people yeah like you can be like a
[ __ ] up journalist and like write evil
things about people but the line in
journalism is that if someone's in the
closet like you cannot and will not yeah
we're like taking pictures of people's
like paparazzi photos of people's kids
and publishing them yeah I also think
the next level of things that
journalists should stop doing is taking
pictures of people out other people's
funerals I know that it's so horrible
those pictures of Bethany at Dennis's
gravesite I've mentioned it twice this
week on the show or one of the most
horrible things I've ever seen
yeah and I think also publishing
information about ongoing criminal cases
when the police require of course that
people don't know of course something
that I'm gonna become an advocate for um
Darren Criss yet not ruining ongoing
police investigation I just think the
media like truly needs to go away
like they're always like the media no
but we are like
you know we're the people's choice even
though we've never wanted People's
Choice Award but I did lose a few years
ago to Jacob Sartorius I just think like
the media like they're always they just
think need to go away okay we'll work on
it okay
next story really crazy turn of events
Jameela Jamil is now denying suffering
from munchausen syndrome there I read
about this in the toasters first yes
okay
there's a thread on Instagram by writer
Tracy Egan Morrissey right so she's not
a crazy like she's a writer she's in
Hollywood like a TV writer yeah and she
has a theory that Jameela Jamil has
Munchausen's syndrome and if we're
watching the Instagram highlights
they're on her Instagram you can check
them out
where she's putting together pieces of
different stories that Jameela Jamil has
told over the years of all these various
injuries a lot of really crazy stories
of injuries and she has come to the
conclusion the Jameela Jamil has
Munchausen's syndrome now Jameela Jamil
is responding she took to Twitter to
knock down the rumors first I'm lying
about my set quote first I'm lying about
my sexuality now I'm being accused of
Munchausen by an unhinged idiot who
didn't even realize in all her quote
research that my car accident injuries
are different because they were two
separate car accidents 13 years apart
you can keep it she went on a lengthy
point-by-point clarification of Egan's
accusations ultimately concluding quote
not afraid of you or your dumb internet
conspiracy theories keep them coming you
just add to my relevance I'm gonna keep
helping people with eating disorders and
changing laws and global policies to
protect kids and their mental health and
there's nothing you can do about it yeah
this whole thing is so weird because
when I watch the stories it's like there
definitely are like inconsistent details
about like the stories that Jamila
Jamila tells excuse me didn't come true
but like I just think she's a flair for
the dramatics and so do I and like
you're on an interview like Jimmy Kimmel
you're gonna like salt up your your
story like I don't think that makes her
a Munchausen this is just Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills all over
again and no good comes of Munchausen's
syndrome yeah but people are fascinated
by it the CAC Joey King that gypsy rose
politician yeah people are it's become
like a
fun thing to like write and talk about
in TV and movies and it is a real
illness but now it's being hurled more
like as an accusation in like if you're
an exaggerator you have Munchausen so I
think in a lot of ways I definitely
suffer from Munchausen's because I like
lie and and make stuff up but it's just
because like exaggerated like interest
injuries or illnesses no I definitely do
I just want you to see have a really low
pain threshold so maybe like II an
injury is more severe to you because
that's how you feel it but if happened
to someone else it wouldn't be right so
I'm not lying I just genuinely like feel
things differently yeah but you know
that biologically redheads actually have
the lowest pain threshold yeah I think
it um excu you right to max oh that's
maybe I left it in the womb and when I
was in there there I was like give me
that [ __ ] because I'm always taking
things that will cuz I'm always taking
things that belong to other people I'm
jealous of what they have that would
actually make sense because I feel like
I have a really high pain tolerance I
don't know if it's just because mentally
I refuse to succumb to the pain or is it
physical actually weirdly been
implementing because I was talking about
this with Olivia like pregnancy
breathing into like painful scenarios
like I had a very very painful stomach
ache the other day and I was doing this
like breathing if you focus on your
breathing you forget about the pain and
it it didn't like 100% work but it
actually there's something to that
method of like focusing on your breath
and not acting like pain is mental
because it's not it's very much physical
but implementing like breathing
technology that you use in pregnancy it
actually really gentle me had a very
painful stomach ache and unbend was like
are you okay because that was like
dramatic no but it works but actually I
did something similar because when I've
been falling asleep like if I have a
headache or if I'm just like having a
hard time falling asleep I realize my
jaws so clenched which probably
contributes my headaches but if I open
my mouth and breathe I will fall and I
focus on that like I will fall asleep
sooner so I've been focusing on my
breathing as well all those meditation
apps like focus on your breathing but it
actually it really does help really I
think I clench my jaw when I sleep
because I don't want to smell my breath
what you're having or you're having
nightmares
no I clench my jaw because I don't want
anyone to have to smell my breath
even do it just day-to-day I just Clint
do you ever have have you ever
experienced this cuz you obviously sleep
with a man every night I do too we're
like you'll flip over in the middle of
the night and like you and Zach are
technically facing each other you could
smell his breath ah maybe like once or
twice but no if actually yes when that
happens I just go a little lower so it's
more like I'm breathing chest no I
experience it like all the time Michelle
Obama's finest work
I been experiencing that like really
frequently and I live I will just like
shove my face my hand in Ben's face and
like move his head oh wow yeah no but
it's just AIT's a thing couple's deal
with there needs to be some shark tank
products you know like overarching like
I'm the breath criminal in our
relationship me and Ben are both equally
guilty so when it's him like he gets a
pass where all the breath he's put up
with me you know by the way we'd even
talk about how we went to polo bar last
night we sat next to Martha Stewart and
she complimented Margeaux ashtrays phone
case and I grabbed her phone was like
can I take a picture of this
Margot's phone case is a heart that says
don't [ __ ] touch me and Martha said
she was gonna send it to all of her
friends on Valentine's Day all of her
guys like that was her Valentine she was
gonna like text the picture and
unfortunately it was raining so Martha
was wearing pants but I did want to see
her sexy legs in real life yeah she's an
icon yeah she was like so she ate a
burger and a piece of chocolate cake
like I just really I want to be Martha
Stewart when I grow up like so famous so
rich like we're go to pull a bar in a
cardigan without makeup and eat a burger
with your friend and split a piece of
cake and take a picture of the snatchers
phone yeah but then she also she
critiqued on Zedeck it it was I would
say she was really like overbearing
she spoke just a lot Margo is eating a
chopped salad that had feta in it and
Margot was like over the feta so she
took the feta out and put it on the
table right next to Margo's bowl of
salad so she didn't put it on like a
little plate or anything she put it
directly on the tablecloth and Martha
like literally was like what is that
right there what are you doing you don't
mark it was like I didn't have a plate
and she goes gonna put it on the table
and Morgan's like I guess not
I know it was like really [ __ ]
awkward shake sorry Martha it was really
funny Martha Martha squash I guess you
could say like we're
friends with Martha Nell yeah friends of
Martha fom fom okay next story Hoda copy
is weighing in on the drama that she
started over Vanessa Vanessa and Nick
Lachey's alleged gift to Jessica Simpson
she isn't loving this us so I was on
watch what happens live last night as we
all know the story now Vanessa keeps
saying she posted the clip on her
Instagram she didn't send the gift
Jessica Simpson but Nick like kind of
did on watch what happens live Hoda
admitted she didn't expect the interview
to go that way she said here's the thing
when I was interviewing Jessica she was
talking about like on what great terms
everyone was she explained like I'm so
happy for them I have children they have
children and she mentioned something I
thought about a gift so I was like oh so
everybody's happy right so when they
came I was like isn't that cool
everybody's friends and then that wasn't
the way it was received in fact she
didn't understand what was going on and
she was actually confused Vanessa Lachey
like really should have let it go she
should have but it's become clear that
it was a game of telephone and the
miscommunication was that there was no
gift
I don't think Jessica told Hoda but
there was a gift like Hoda thought there
was a gift and Vanessa should have just
let it go because oh you got credit for
sending a gift how lovely and sweet of
you I'm just going to take that win yeah
I think that um the whole scenario is so
iconic like I'm living for the celebrity
miscommunication and like the PGM Hoda
Kotb like caught in the middle like she
was really just trying to like mend more
fences and ended up like breaking those
fences down that would be like if we had
a like about right they made things
worse I was really struggling because I
was talking arrests I was like yes okay
MJ and then I was like I'm like yeah
[ __ ] Reza but like I really like them
supposed so much and I plan on being the
candy crowley like the mediator between
them and i think it just goes to show
you that like well I do think breads we
should have turned up to the hospital
but if he were here you probably would
have a reason as to why he didn't and
then I would have believed it oh yes
thank you for explaining very true
there's two sides to every story and
like it's not always just so cut-and-dry
Jackie
once again I stand firmly in the middle
right where we're happy to be okay um
anyways I'm this drama and it has bitten
funny fodder and I'm just glad it's like
more press for Jessica Simpson's book
which is number one one New York Times
bestseller had to believe that it would
be I mean I knew she was gonna be
bestseller and I knew she was probably
gonna be number one nationally across
all categories
she would have been number one
guard list but the fact that the book is
a masterpiece has so much juice in it
and that it's a news story every single
day like I think she must have sold
100,000 copies you know there are
definitely it makes it better that the
book is really good and even if it was
written like a piece of [ __ ] it would
have been a New York Times bestseller
but there are plenty of New York Times
number one national bestsellers that are
pieces of [ __ ] yes yes but they're like
celebrity memoirs so you buy them and of
course you know and you buy it to
support because you're a fan yes like I
bought books of people that I really
liked like in support never read them
just because I like like them and I want
to support them yeah and I bought books
of people I like it's important I read
them and I didn't think you were good
pieces of [ __ ] yeah okay I just have to
say these new characters are so
comfortable and I think th geo is so
much like more at home here agreed and
we're getting our th EO camera set up
it'll be up by Tuesday's show so I just
think like we are really like changing
Gio's life yeah but like the lives of so
many people I love these couches I want
them in my house they're actually so
[ __ ] cute extreme was like poppin off
when we went live obviously because
they'd never seen couches so sickening
in the eyes everyone was complaining and
I'm just want to say like I [ __ ] love
that they don't I don't know what they
were saying I don't want to put words in
anyone's mouth but there was a lot of
like oh my god I can't there's a lot of
what was the backlash I don't know what
could they possibly have said I don't
know they like the chairs better like we
can't oh my god everybody [ __ ] hated
though I literally I'm taking those
chairs to the [ __ ] incinerator like
tomorrow
I hate those [ __ ] chairs we are gonna
keep two because they're like you know
iconic relics but when we first got them
we thought we were like so sickening
like yes Persian vibes but now like I
literally offer them out this window
also speaking of Jessica Simpson's book
and the power of the toasters we were
just talking about how on Amazon right
now they're like recommending as a
bundle the husband's secret the first
bread in the book
Jessica Simpson's book and the second
redheads book club book red white and
royal blue so I just think that's beast
to the power the toasters that's like so
crazy
sickening sickening by the way i am
reading such a good book right now that
the toasters recommended i read called
where the crawdads sang and at first i
was like this is just not my kind of
book but it is so gripping and so good
that if you're looking for an actually
good book i recommend i love a gripping
book I really do being stuff yeah some
books are encrypting and
fine to be finished I story always want
to be gripped no oh two more
look we've been sitting here for like
three hours because we were waiting yeah
ouch is waiting for this a busy morning
busy busy busy
okay oops next story a little bit more
drama Rose McGowan slams Natalie
Portman's quote deeply offensive Oscar's
outfit and Natalie Portman is responding
to the slamming eye I have to say I'm
like a living for this I know it's
terrible women should be supporting
other women but this was hilarious yeah
she just said something anything a lot
of people were thinking and only she
could say so Rose McGowan took to
Facebook to share her take on Natalie
Portman's quote protests at the Oscars
where she wore the names of women
directors embroided into her yes the
best director category had know women
who they people think read a Gerwig I
didn't see little women so I can't say
they think that she was snubbed so
Natalie Portman wore a cape and on the
edge of the Cape and had like ten names
of female directors who she felt had
been snubbed yes so Rose McGowan said
quote some thoughts some thoughts on
Natalie Portman and her Oscar quote
protest the kind of protest that gets
rave reviews from the mainstream media
for its bravery brave no not by a
longshot
more like an actress acting the part of
someone who cares as so many of them do
she went on to write that she finds
Portman's type of activism quote deeply
offensive to those of us who do they
actually do the work I'm not writing
this out of bitterness I am writing out
of disgust I just want her to other
actresses to walk the walk I don't know
you know I I kind of have to agree I
think Rose McGowan sometimes it's like a
little nuts but she's so right like
Natalie Portman is like now getting
praise from everyone like she's so
strong when what she did is like not
that brave and seeing as how now there's
like a picture going around it's like a
list of Natalie Portman has a production
company and all the movies they've ever
made they've only had one female
director and her name was Natalie
Portman so it's like you can walk the
walk in your dress but you've never
hired a female director like it's just I
could see where the frustration from
people like Rose McGowan whose entire
careers have now been dedicated to the
fight for equality I could see how it's
frustrating that everyone thinks Natalie
Portman's a hero yeah and like this is
not brave wearing a dress you know and
making a statement and getting praise
from media that's not brief you know
going up against Harvey Weinstein in
total and told that you're a liar that's
brave Jackie I totally agree and I think
this speaks I think
reason why her statement resonates with
me so much Rose McGowan is because it
speaks to this and I think we were
talking about this yesterday about
someone else where the celebrities just
like talk a talk and don't walk the walk
we were saying it literally yesterday
when we were talking about that time it
changes and take their private planes
and that's what we were saying yesterday
that there now rewiring old gowns in the
name of sustainable fashion and it's
like finally you're actually walking the
walk but Natalie Portman has issued a
response she said I agree with miss
McGowan that it is inaccurate to call me
brave for wearing a garment a garment
with women's names on it she said in a
statement
brave is a term I'm more strongly
associate with actions like those of the
women who have been testifying against
Harvey Weinstein the last few weeks
under incredible pressure the past few
years have seen a blossoming of
directing opportunities for women due to
the collective efforts of many people
who have been calling out the system the
gift has been these incredible films I
hope that what was intended as a simple
nod to them does not distract from their
great achievements it is true I've only
made a few films with women in my long
career I've only gotten the chance to
work with female directors a few times
I've made short commercials music videos
and features with six female directors
short and Michelle's don't count music
videos I can't know also to me why this
whole and that was it
unfortunately the unmade films I had
tried to make our ghost history so she's
saying oh she tried to make films with
him in write to me like I feel like this
Natalie Portman thing was so insincere
one because it just felt random I don't
feel like she's been like super vocal
and an activist for change for women too
she is like she was like you know at one
point the star of you know every award
show and to me it's like she was rolling
through through these award shows like
somewhat irrelevant and to me it also
seems like a grasp for attention which
is like that's not what activism is for
mm-hmm to make you now be in every
magazine because your dress had some
names on it I just I I hate to you know
tear women down when they're trying to
help but to me this didn't seem like it
was really genuine but yeah it was like
here in this situation the problem like
that
the real culprit is the media because
Rose McGowan sub said that the people
are calling her bracelet Natalie Portman
was kind of just trying to do a nice
thing if you if you want to like just
take it on its face yeah but the problem
is that all of the praise that she gets
for doing something so simple mom and
they never give praise or attention
like that to people like Rose McGowan
who are constantly doing way braver [ __ ]
yes so once again the media is the
problem here I pronounce McGowan wrong I
just print like how do you say McGowan
oh it was worth it like how I still say
Lori Loughlin yeah because it is that's
what it looks like to me
yeah we're McKenna or when I say LeeAnn
Moriarty I like you have such a hard
time pronouncing that author's name well
when they see someone say man I'm not
sure how to pronounce and I just I do it
phonetically ya know and you're like
emphasizing too much on every letter
it's not LeAnn Moriarty it's Leon
Moriarty you know I keep saying they are
in Moriarty
yeah and Moriarty Moriarty yeah so I
apologize but that's just my cross to
bear in LA yeah okay Phaethon final
story something I'm like just about sort
of because we always talk about not
always probably once about how you know
the the new popular vegetable that's
just like the sexiest vegetable and the
stalks gonna go up and I literally if
you're a commodities trader like this is
a story I wait every year with bated
breath to see what the vegetable of the
year is gonna be because I'm the number
one vegetable fan I'm just always
curious like it just comes out of
nowhere like it was recently cauliflower
and then everything had cauliflower and
if you bought stock in cauliflower like
you're probably so do vegetables have
stocks commodities trading you can buy
socks and commodities exciting yeah it's
not like this Wall Street under feet
news Robin Hood that's not a bad anyways
so it's been kale it's been brussel
sprouts it's been cauliflower and we
finally have our next victim you guys
what do you think it is I mean it's so
hard because I've literally never eaten
a vegetable in my entire life except a
cucumber like one time in 1997 but it
was an accident
so I don't really go to restaurants and
order vegetables but if you like
broccolini broccolini nope it is sorry
mushrooms
oh I feel that even though I feel like
they had a moment like years ago they're
fabulous I can't believe I didn't think
of it sooner
move over kale there was a new celebrity
in the produce aisle mushrooms CNN
business with the jokes some nerd like
who's like 75 years old right above
people are scooping up mushrooms so
quickly that producers are scrambling to
keep pace with burgeoning demand what we
haven't run out as yet but we're
definitely trying to keep up the horror
mushrooms running out what will we do
it's very tragic notes said gal Ferran
toe
to run her family's third generation
business Bella mushroom farms in Chester
County Pennsylvania do you think it's in
winchestertonfieldville or is it mmm
maybe a little a little south via
Chester County about a two-hour drive
south west from winchestertonfieldville
is the epicenter of mushroom production
in the United States well we call it the
mushroom mecca said Ferran toe the area
accounts for more than 60% of all
domestic mushroom production coming from
more than 50 local family-owned farms
this is quite intercept yeah I would I
feel like we could get a documentary
about Bella mushroom farms yeah Netflix
is all over it already
um I'm here for this I love mushrooms
they're so tasty a good Portobello
burger no I'm not really into mushrooms
except the kind that make you get [ __ ]
up oh yeah that's why they're going up
in stock yeah that's actually true
everybody watched GUP episode one where
they tried psychedelic mushrooms and now
they're like I want to try mushrooms so
they're going to their local grocery
store eating mushrooms in the aisle and
pretending that they're all
hallucinogenic have you ever done no
listen no genic no uni there's something
no I'm good and I wish it was like cool
enough so I'd go to Jamaica or wherever
they went and goop and like try
hallucinogenics and honestly that
episode I think it was supposed to make
everyone like want to try it but I was
immediately turned off to it like they
were crying like they didn't know why
they were like all these shaman were
like holding them I would be I get the
[ __ ] off me
it just it did not seem like anything
I'd be remotely interested in I just
think if there was ever a time that I
was gonna do that like it the time has
passed
ya know I'm all no doors close yeah the
window is sealed shut okay anything else
we need to do we can we get down in
Miami you know me to be hitting up 11
strip club become like my inner stripper
I'm really excited
anyways no those are the Fast Five
stories I feel like they were deeply
profound hi Theodora foramina oh he was
so good guys this has been an absolute
pleasure we'll be back on Tuesday with
our first episode of the week we will
have our couches better situated we are
gonna have our new window film we got
our new camera set up so it's all very
exciting if you're listening as a
podcast hi why don't you join us on
YouTube one day this thing has a podcast
sorry for the sirens in what you already
heard and what you're about to hear and
MJ second yeah the MJ segment was irons
were so bad oh my god that's like the
one issue in our studio we have to still
figure out that we can't I know
maybe different microphones or something
these are the best in the biz I mean
we're always working striving towards a
better toast but like that
like our cross to bear is the sirens you
know what it's New York City
that's that's literally how we live out
so it's a pretty price you pay its a
price you pay thank you so much for
listening to my life for six months
sabbatical the Millennium morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube
so if you're watching us on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe leave a
comment were also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found set
Spotify iTunes stitcher public videocast
box all the places however you choose to
listen to podcasts find out some I'm
toast
though we are gone Friday and Monday we
will have new patron episodes up for you
so that you do not miss your daily dose
of morning toast at as patreon.com slash
the morning toast we have some great
podcast episodes coming I might do a
little anniversary something something
with may mersen's my anniversaries on
Monday how crazy is that the whole year
since I got wasted and saying Country
Strong and I thought I was doing a good
job and then I watched a video and I
actually sing like a piece of [ __ ]
it was beautiful it's been a whole year
since I've had a concussion on my
wedding night so yeah happy Valentine's
Day everyone
and if you're celebrating Valentine's
Day I think you should just rethink that
okay I if you're celebrating guys oh my
god Theo just farted oh my that's also
the power of a Theo fart like it's
deadly but I still love you I think
Valentine's Day should really be for
everyone single relationship dating
engage married like just enjoy
Valentine's Day with a V yeah like
cupcakes cookies and just there are
people you love just cuz you're not
having sex with them alright I'm
literally about to vomit the as fart
smells so bad we love you guys so much
have a great long weekend don't drink
and drive we will see you on Tuesday
bye
you